some major retailers are turning towards
social media influencers after a tough
few years for traditional change chains
big-name brands like Brooke stones Sears
Payless David's Bridal and Gymboree are
seeing bankruptcy protect are seeking
bankruptcy protection some analysts are
calling it a retail apocalypse CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
looks at how Nordstrom and other
traditional names are modernizing their
marketing strategies Michelle good
morning good morning they are indeed
retailers like Nordstrom's needed to
find new ways to connect with shoppers
holiday traffic was slow in 2018 but the
company posted better than expected
earnings last quarter thanks in part to
influencer arielle Charnas they're
hoping to turn the 31 year olds 'likes
into sales he did these turtleneck
bodysuits and add like some ruching on
the side and if you're wondering who
influences RAL Charnas the most look no
further than her 1.2 million Instagram
followers I get a lot of it from the
girls who follow me I mean I don't think
I'd be able to come up with this without
them it's a brand she launched a decade
ago when she started posting some of her
daily looks on her blog something Navy
I've just pretty much been putting
together looks documenting them sharing
the best places to shop where to get
affordable pieces Charnas is
trend-setting recommendations on her
blog and now her Instagram have
generated a young and enthusiastic fan
base now followers hoping to copy her
style have a new way to connect it's
like a camisole with a short this is
something Navy a clothing and
accessories line designed by Charnas
exclusively for Nordstrom how do you go
from being a curator to a designer so
what was great for me and well what's
great for influencers in general is that
we get that feedback from our followers
that brands don't I can see what they
gravitate towards when I pose so you
know if it's a bright pink sweater
instead of a beige letter I know I need
to make more bright pink sweaters I know
the girl that follows me I know she
loves fashion but I also know that she
still wants to look pretty and
sexy China's bears it all on Instagram
posting not only her fashion but
seemingly intimate moments with her
family you know you're putting all of
yourself kind of out there yes that's
what has created my my following is
because nothing's edited everything's
super real and authentic I draw the line
when it comes to certain things with my
kids but my job is to share my my
journey in my life that journey now
includes five collections with
Nordstrom's since the partnership began
last year from swimwear to basics to
shoes and jewelry each collection
tailored to her followers tastes and for
Nordstrom's something maybe has given
them something to talk about the first
two launches were the biggest in the
company's history
they literally sold out in 24 hours one
time another time they crashed the
website within one hour they made a
million dollars in one day so she is
bringing in followers of her she's
bringing in shoppers and she's bringing
in dollars USA Today national business
correspondent Charisse Joan says
Nordstrom is cashing in on char nez's
relatability they find her both
accessible and aspirational right
influencers are the new authorities and
so for an old-school retailer like a
Nordstrom to partner with a social-media
influencer it's really important to
introduce themselves to a new audience
and still survive at a time when
old-school retailers are really
struggling we're a live guy
for the first time this month the
something Navy collection includes
children's clothing and accessories how
cute is that Charnas his daughters are
both her muses and models it's safe to
say you're the retail industries safe
bet or would you say are you saving
retail for the long run
I think we're saving it I think
influencers are the best way to keep
retail alive it doesn't hurt that the
something Navy collection also has an
accessible price tag and speaking of
affordability Walmart has also jumped on
the influencer bandwagon its teamed up
with the grade-school youtube star
behind ryan toysreview
to create a line of toys and t-shirts
and guess what he's got a teen Milken
subscriber he's like 6 or 7 yeah I think
I remember we did a story on him but I'm
fascinated by her by Ariel but your face
artist said it all like what when you
were listening the numbers are really
staggering about what she does think
about this I went shopping before I even
met her yeah I never heard of something
Navy guess what I bought we found after
I was like oh my god I want to go look
at something I like her
Thank You Michelle